now that you've seen some examples of
the chain rule in use i think
the actual definition of the chain rule
might be more digestible now so let me
give you the actual definition of the
chain rule let's say i have a function f
of x
f of x
and it equals
uh i'll just use somewhat h
h
of g of x
right and you remember all of this from
composite functions so the chain rule
just says that the derivative of f of x
or f prime of x
is equal to
the derivative of this inner function
g prime of x
times the derivative of this h function
h prime of x
h prime but it's not going to be just h
prime of x it's going to be h prime of
g of x
so let's let's let's apply that to some
examples like we were doing before and i
think i think it'll make some sense so
let's say we had
let me say f of x
is equal to
x squared
plus 5x
plus 3
all of this
to the
fifth power
so in this example what's h of x what's
g of x and well you know what f of x is
well let's say g of x would be this
inner function this inner function
so we would say
let's let me pick a different color
g of x
here is
x squared
plus five x
plus three
right it's this stuff
that's g of x and what is
h well h of g of x is this whole thing
so what would h of x be well h of x is
just
h of x
this is this is h of g of x but h of x
would just be x to the fifth right
because this expression is you took this
entire g of x and you put it in for x
right here i think that makes sense
right if you take this entire expression
and you substitute x here for this
entire expression you get this
expression
right and this shows that this is equal
to
h
of
g of x
right if you just take this blue part
and substitute for x you get this entire
expression so the chain rule just tells
us that the derivative of this
that f prime of x and i have a feeling
i'm going to run out of space
f prime of x well actually before i do
anything let's figure out the
derivatives of g of x and h of x
g of x or g prime of x
so let me draw a little line here to
divide it out i know i'm running out of
space
so
g prime
of x is equal to
two
x
plus 5 right
2x plus 5 and the derivative 3 is just 0
right and what's what's the derivative
of
h of x h of x h prime of x
is equal to
x to the fourth
right
so the chain rule just says that the
derivative of this entire
composite function
is just
and let me just write it down here i am
i'm doing this to optimally confuse you
the derivative of this entire function
is just
g prime of x well we figured out what g
prime of x is here it's two x plus five
so it's
2x plus 5
times
h times h prime of g of x
so it's h prime of g of x well h prime
of x is 5x to the fourth
but we want h prime of g of x so h prime
of g of x would be
h prime
of g of x
would equal 5
times g of x
to the fourth right and we know g of x
is just this whole thing
so it would be times five
and this whole thing
x squared plus five x
plus three all of that to the fourth
power
i think i have truly truly confused you
so i'm going to try to do a couple of
more examples let me
clear this
okay so let me let me write it up here
again so
if we say that
f of x
is equal to h
of g of x
then
f prime of x
is equal to
g prime
of x
times
h
prime
of g of x
so i'll do another example let's say
that
let's say that
g of x
is equal to
x
to the seventh
minus
three
x to the minus three
and let's say that
h of x
is equal to
let's do something reasonably let's do
something reasonably straightforward
let's say h of x is
is
x to the minus 10.
so what is f of x f of x is just h of g
of x and y this this should be a bit of
a a reminder from composite functions so
let's say h
of
g of x
would just be
you take g of x and you substitute for x
here so it would just
let me show you be
and would be just be this expression
x to the seventh
minus three x to the minus third
and then all of that
to the minus tenth power right so this
is our f of x
and this is of course is equal to f of x
right because f of x is equal to h of g
of x
i know this is very confusing but bear
with me maybe you have to watch the
video twice and it'll start making more
sense but we want to now figure out what
f prime of x is
so f prime of x
well the chain rule tells us all it is
is we take the derivative of g of x
right so the derivative of g of x is one
that's easy
all right hopefully is easy by now
derivative of g of x is
seven x to the sixth and minus three
times minus three is plus
nine
x to the minus 4 right i just took minus
3 and went down 1.
so that's g prime of x
that's g prime of x
and then
times
i'll switch to the brown
h prime of g of x
well what's h prime of x h prime of x is
that's easy that's just minus 10
times x to the minus 11 right
but we want to do h
prime of g of x instead of having an x
here we're going to substitute that x
with the entire g of x expression so
this is just
times 10
times something to the minus 11 and that
something is just g of x
x to the seventh
minus three x to the minus
three and there's our answer f prime of
x
is
the derivative of kind of the inner
function the g of x
times the derivative of the outer
function
but instead of it just being applied to
x it would be applied to the entire g of
x right instead of an x being here
maybe i've confused you more let me do
one quick example just to show you that
you don't have to kind of do this whole
h of g of x
every time
so if i have
f of x
is equal
to five
times
i don't know
minus x to the eighth
plus x to the minus eighth
all of that over to the fifth power
so one i just so if i want to figure out
f prime of x
i just take the derivative of this
inner function i guess i could call it
so that's
minus eight
x to the seventh right
minus eight because let's just take the
negative eight
x to the minus ninth
times the derivative of this larger
function so five times five is 25
times something
to the 4th right and that something is
just going to be this expression
minus x to the 8th
plus
x to the minus 8. and we're done you
could simplify it you could multiply
this 25 out and do et cetera et cetera
hopefully this gives you more of an
intuition of what the chain rule is all
about and i'm going to do a lot more
examples in the next couple of
presentations as well see you soon